翻訳: Kaori Otake
校正: Yuri Ueda
こんにちは 安城西中学校郷土芸能研究会です
三河万歳の誕生は 約450年前に遡ることができ
安城の伝統芸能として今に受け継がれ
国の重要無形文化財に指定されています
本日演じます「三河御殿万歳」は
新春に鶴と亀が訪れ 家を建てる柱の１本ずつに
日本中から神様が呼び集められ 瓦をふせます
そこへ七福神が入ってきて
賑やかにお祝いをします
みなさまの悪事災難が遠くに去り
これからの健康と幸せを祈って
演じたいと思います
最後までお聴きください
(太夫) お願いします
(全員) お願いします
(拍手)
(拍子木)
(唄)
(唄 終了)
(拍子木)
(太夫) ありがとうございました
(全員) ありがとうございました
(拍手)
私たちは 三河万歳と部活を
両立してやってきました
大変でしたが 地域の方と交流を深める中で
お年寄りの方を笑顔にすることができ
続けて来て良かったと思いました
これからも 伝統継承を忘れずに
先輩から受け継いだことを
後輩に伝えていきたいです
(英語) 私たちは 三河万歳と部活を
(英語) 両立してやってきました
(英語) 両立は難しかったですが
(英語) しかしお年寄りをパフォーマンスで
(英語) 笑顔にすることができました
(英語) 三河万歳は先輩から後輩へ
(英語) 受け継がれています
(英語) 私たちもこの伝統芸能を
(英語) 伝えていきたいです
(英語) ありがとうございます
(英語)(全員) ではまた
(拍手)